hi there everyone I have been really
looking forward to making this video
last week I had the opportunity to test
a brand new prototype ESC from Fetch
that uses a new method of driving our
Motors never before seen in fpv and I
thought it gives us a perfect
opportunity to do a deep dive on how our
esc's Drive our Motors and how this new
ftech sfoc ESC takes everything to the
next level it's a lot to cover in one
video this is going to be a technical
Deep dive let's get into it all right
before we dive into the depths of ESC
commutation I think it's important to
first recap the motor connections to
each of our brushless DC motors although
every BLC motor has several coils
schematically they can all be drawn as
three phases a b and c drawn here in
purple green and orange each phase is
then wrapped around three or four coils
inside the motor depending on whether
it's a nine Poole motor in which case
each phase goes around three coils or a
12 pole motor in which case each phase
is going to go around four coils the ESC
is then connected to the motor at along
the three motor wires X Y and Z and you
can see that each of the terminals X Y
and Z is connected to two of the phases
and it makes this sort of triangular
diagram when we spin a brushless DC
motor it acts as a generator and it
produces a back EMF current on the
phases because of the Symmetry between
the motor being spun and driving the
motor to spin the back EMF current
actually indicates the ideal shape of
the driving current for that particular
motor so this uh graph was taken by
Felix at Fetch and this is for a t-motor
F40 Pro and you can see that the back
EMF current on each of the phases looks
very very close to a sinusoid nearly a
perfect sinoid and that means that the
ideal driving current for this motor is
also nearly perfectly sinusoidal and if
we drive it with that ideal current
we'll get the most performance the most
torque and power and we'll also get the
best possible efficiency from the motor
there are several different ways that we
can drive a motor but the simplest
method is called Block commutation in
Block commutation we simply Drive the
phase of the motor whenever the ideal
driving current is more than 50% so here
in the black line we have the ideal
driving current given by the back EMF of
the the motor and we simply say well
whenever that driving current is greater
than 50% I'll drive the phase and
whenever that Ideal Driving current is
less than 50% I won't drive the phase
and similarly when it's in the reverse
Direction I'll drive it in the reverse
Direction and then I'll I won't drive it
and this is a really simple method this
is basically just rounding you know more
than a half round up to one drive the
phase less than a half round down to
zero and don't drive the phase whenever
the phase is not being driven the
voltage created by the back EMF current
can be measured and that can be used to
determine the rotor position so the ESC
looks for What's called the zero
crossing that's where the back EMF
current and therefore back EMF voltage
crosses zero and that indicates that the
magnet is precisely opposite the coil
and it basically tells the ESC where the
rotor is so that it knows how to drive
the rotor round and round in reality
block commutation like this uces some
problems firstly turning the phase on
and off very quickly introduces spikes
because you've got fields in the coils
being created and destroyed very rapidly
and whenever you've got a field
collapsing quickly you get a spiking
current and you can see this on the
input current to the ESC so this is
called a demagnetization spike it's when
the field in the coil is collapsing and
the ESC draws more current as a result
the second problem is that 33% of the
time you are not driving the phase so
you could be driving the phase a little
bit and getting a bit more torque and a
bit more power out of the motor but
instead you're not driving the phase and
you're listening for the zero Crossing
on the back EMF voltage so you're
missing some time where you could be
putting power into the motor and getting
useful work done um because you're
listening for that zero Crossing block
commutation is also not the most
efficient way to drive the motor because
the drive current that you're applying
is not the same shape as the back EMF
current from the motor it's not that
ideal sinusoid so you're underd driving
the motor at certain times when you're
listening for the back EMF and you're
overdriving the motor at other times
when you're driving the phase full
before the back EMF current in the motor
has reached its peak so block
commutation is by no means the perfect
approach to driving a motor sinusoidal
commutation is another way to drive a
motor and it alleviates some of the
issues with block Comm ation if we're
using a pwm drive which we are for all
of our fpv esc's then using pwm it is
possible to create sinusoidal driving
voltages so rather than just driving the
phase fully on or fully off you actually
vary the drive voltage on each of those
terminals X Y and Z in a sinusoidal way
to get a sinusoidal voltage across each
of the phases
abnc and this is the most efficient and
the smoothest way to drive a motor
because it provides
exactly the right shape of driving
current that matches the back EMF so we
know the motor wants to accept a
sinusoid driving current and you're
giving it one however just pure sinus
oil commutation also has some problems
the first problem with sinusoidal
commutation is switching losses when the
fets in our esc's are switching they
momentarily dissipate a lot more power
and this is the same reason why when you
overclock a PC the the CPU gets hot it's
because you're making the uh transistors
in the CPU switch faster and so they
dissipate more
power when we're doing block commutation
we don't have to worry too much about
switching losses when we are holding the
phase to zero which is for quite a lot
of the time we're not switching the fets
at all we just have the fet between the
motor phase and ground on and it stays
on that holds the phase to zero and we
don't do any
switching when we're driving the phase
to a positive voltage if we're at Full
Throttle 100% we don't do any switching
either because we're just connecting
battery voltage straight across that
phase and we're not
switching if we're at part throttle then
we do have to switch the fets when we're
driving the phase but we still are not
switching the fets when we're just
holding the phase to
ground so with block commutation you
only get switching losses when you're
driving the phase and only when you're
driving the phase at less than Full
Throttle so you get the minimum
switching losses with sinusoidal drive
we are basically partly driving the
phase all of the time there's only an
instant where we have the phase fully on
and there's only an instant where we
have the phase at zero all the rest of
the time we are driving the phase
somewhere between 0 and 100% and that
means that we're switching the fets that
means that we're introducing switching
losses and that's happening all the time
everywhere and that does cause the ESC
to dissipate a bit more power power and
it will cause the ESC to heat up a bit
more than if you were doing block
commutation the second problem with
sinusoidal commutation is to do with the
driving voltage with block commutation
at Full Throttle you are getting the
full battery voltage across every phase
so let's look here at the terminal X and
terminal Zed between X and Zed we are
getting full battery voltage that means
full battery voltage across phase a and
that's giving us maximum power with
sinusoidal Drive let's look at the same
point so we between red and blue you can
see that there's nowhere where we get
full battery voltage across that phase
at most we get about 87% of battery
voltage across the phase at the peak
where the two sinusoids are as far apart
as
possible this reduces the maximum torque
and maximum power that we can get from a
motor with sinusoidal Drive compared to
what we can achieve with block
commutation if you love these type of
deep technical videos you are going to
adore AOS Labs I've brought together all
of my product testing results on Motors
batteries props esc's and vtx's all into
one place to help you find the highest
performing and best value components for
your next fpv build there's links down
in the video description why not click
through and check it out you won't find
this data anywhere else svm commutation
or space Vector modulation is a really
elegant way of solving a lot of the
problems that we saw with pure
sinusoidal commutation whilst
maintaining all of its advantages with
svm you can see that the driving voltage
spends a long time at zero volts you see
it's zero here and then this yellow
phase is zero all the way along here all
the time that the phase is at zero we're
not switching so we're saving on
Switching losses and also we can see
that at Full Throttle each phase does
receive the full driving voltage from
the battery full battery voltage and
therefore you get full torque and power
but you may be wondering how does this
weird double hump shape provide a nice
sinusoidal driving current for our motor
it doesn't look anything like a sinusoid
well the answer is really interesting
the way SPM works is it does a
subtraction on the signals on each of
the phases so we start with our Pure
sinusoidal voltage this phase voltage
here and we subtract the svm signal
which is this sort of weird wave shape
and this wave shape actually comes from
the minimum of all of the three phases
so you can see here if we just look at
the minimum voltage of all the three
phases it starts off blue and then the
minimum is now yellow and then the
minimum is red so we just take that
minimum voltage and that's our svm
voltage signal which we subtract from
all the phases and that gives us our
weird double hump svm voltage signal but
what does it do to the current well
obviously L we start off with a nice
sinusoidal driving current because we've
started off with a nice sinusoidal
driving voltage but then we subtract the
svm current signal but the svm current
signal is zero because we're applying
the same voltage to all the phases so
there's no voltage across the phases and
therefore no current through any of the
phases so the current signal we're
subtracting is zero which means that
this strange looking svm Drive voltage
provides exactly the same current
through each of the phases as our
original sinusoidal driving voltage so
we get a beautiful sinusoidal driving
current despite not having a beautiful
sinusoidal driving
voltage also and it's a subtle thing
you'll notice that our phase voltage
ranged from 100% to 0% it covered the
full range of our battery voltage but
our svm voltage only gets up to about 80
85% or Al of full battery voltage this
means that we have extra headro for more
power we can increase the amplitude of
our driving voltage we can push these
humps up to 100% And we can get more
torque and power out of the motor
without having to increase the battery
voltage and that's the genius of space
Vector
modulation let me show you now another
graph again this is from Felix at fetch
showing you his svm commutation in
reality on an actual motor this is again
a t-motor F40 pro at Full Throttle you
can see that the svm voltage starts at
zero basically the phase is low that's
this red section here where it's along
0% and then you can see that we use pwm
drive to simulate that increasing sinuso
voltage it Peaks here at full voltage
for a little while then it comes down
again you can see it's pwm again so the
voltage is a little bit less than full
then it goes back up to full voltage for
this hump here
and then down to zero again using that
pwm drive and then he's also kindly
measured the phase current for us and
you can see that it's remarkably close
to this perfectly sinusoidal phase
current and it's very very close to the
back EMF current of the motor which
makes svm drive very very efficient
however there is one problem with pure
sinusoidal drive that svm cannot solve
and that is that with SPM every phase is
being driven all of the time we always
have access active driving current
through the phase let's look at Phase a
it's always being driven I mean maybe
just at an instant there's no driving
current but it's for an instant and then
we're driving in the opposite direction
and this makes it impossible to listen
for the back EMF zero Crossing directly
you remember with block commutation we
had a period where we weren't driving
the phase and that was when we would
listen for the back EMF of the motor so
that we would know where the rotor is
relative to the coil well withm we don't
have that
information instead with svm you have to
measure the current in each phase all
the time and you have to measure the
voltage that you're applying to each
phase and then you do a calculation to
work out the back EMF based on the
voltage and current this final slide
highlights the big step forward that
fetch are taking with this new sfoc ESC
previous esc's with sinusoid or drive be
they fatte bl32 or am32
have always had to modify this svm
driving voltage with a zero Drive period
to listen for the back EMF from the
motor to determine the rotor position
relative to the coil and make sure that
the ESC is in sync with the rotation of
the motor this period of zero Drive
modifies the perfect sinusoidal current
and it creates this slightly Jagged
waveform you can see that it's a much
closer approximation to a sinusoid than
block commutation so it's better than
block commutation but it's by no means a
perfect
sinoid this new sfoc ESC from fatch
takes this a step further it doesn't
need to have this zero Drive period in
the waveform anymore the sfoc ESC is
measuring the current through the phase
and the voltage across the phase all of
the time and if you know both the
current and the voltage through the
phase as well as some parameters about
the motor you can calculate the back EMF
that means that the ftech ESC can
calculate the back EMF at any point
during this waveform so unlike a
previous ESC where you can only know the
rotor position at three times so you
know the rotor position here here and
here with the sfoc ESC it can calculate
the rotor position continuously it
always knows exactly where the rotor is
so that gives you more resolution on
your timing and that means the motor
will run slly
smoother also you're getting a perfect
sinusoidal waveform there's no Jagged
bits because of zero drive time which
means that the motor is going to run
smoother and more efficient and you also
driving the motor all the time which
means you are maximizing the amount of
torque and power that you can get out of
the motor so are we going to see this
approach used in other esc's possibly
but there are some specific Hardware
requirements to measure the back EMF in
this way you have to have a shunt resist
on at least one of the phases of each
motor so that you can measure the
current through the phase as well as the
voltage across it to calculate the
backf most esc's in fpv at the moment
only have one shunt resistor for the
whole ESC it's over on the battery leads
and it's used to measure the current
being consumed by all four of the motors
so it wouldn't be appropriate for this
type of back EMF calculation the ftech
sfoc CC appears to have two shunt
resistors for each of the uh individual
Motors so you can see motor 1 2 3 4 and
what look to be two shun resistors next
to the microcontrollers and gate drivers
so that brings us to the end of this
deep dive on the different commutation
methods that are used in fpv esc's I
really enjoyed learning about all this
stuff and putting together this video
and I really hope you enjoyed it as well
if you want to support more videos like
this then please check out the links
down the video description support me
directly on patreon or indirectly using
any of the affiliate links I would
really appreciate appreciate it that's
all I have for you for today so until
next time I wish you all very very happy
[Music]
flying